[Music]
hello
and welcome to psytrek on our first
birthday
yay
we're one years old me
we're walking we're talking
we're saying inappropriate words
occasionally stormy yes
yes
but
this is your sci-fi tv and movie channel
as always and as always i am
joined by stormy bear
hello
how you doing have you got me cake
i'm doing well the cake was lovely the
cake was lovely i've got cake bar
got cake behind me there you go we have
cake
but
we're here just to celebrate our
birthday with all events
ellie is one of the people that i should
go in the list of people i want to thank
because
they've always been with us on the
channel i've had comments off them for i
don't know if it's you're here or she i
don't think i've ever asked
but this is one of those people that's
always been with us from the beginning
i'm just going to prove we're not woke
as [ __ ] we're just not working
them
but yeah
we're here to celebrate at the one year
of sidekick yeah one year do you
remember when we had that conversation
when we thought we should talk about
star trek sometimes
the um ellie's a guy he's a guy he's
why
is it ellie or eli
eli maybe
um
i should start asking particularly the
subscribers that have been with us a
long time i should probably ask them
things but being british i don't really
ask people stuff
um i i don't think i've ever asked
anything personal about you stormy like
ever like i know what you do for a
living
right other than that and you've got a
girlfriend yeah and there's a grand baby
on the other side of the door so if you
hear screaming
that's what that is
cute so and you go granby um yeah and i
do know a few personal things about you
to be fair a little few little things we
talked about but but yeah as an english
person i don't generally ask it's not
that i don't care
well ask away what do you want to know
that i might be able to answer on live
stream
how big [ __ ] now uh
well it depends on okay i know more more
eli is in french man so i know more
about what you like from a tv point of
view
brooks
okay if you're gonna go on holiday
tomorrow anywhere in the world where
would you go antarctica
oh that's a good one i want to see
holiday
trying to survive
huh
is that a holiday or are you just trying
to survive
no that's a holiday
who the hell would you like in
antarctica go punch a penguin
punch a pink one no i would not punch a
pink one
emperor penguins are quite large they're
like you know almost a meter high
you know you're thinking about punching
a penguin now don't you
i wonder if it would fall over and
bounce but look like a weeble
oh my god
you know back in the 60s they had those
blow up things and one up you know like
a clown or whatever you could punch and
oh
weebles wobble but they don't fall down
oh my god that comes back later
yes weebles i remember
i think a penguin would be like a weeble
but they had these uh things as like a
blow-up doll it was just this big on
long with it had like a really heavy
base like sand in the in this inflatable
doll it was about a yard tall
and you could punch it and then come
back but typically there were clowns but
they also had a version that was a
penguin
and you could do it with a real penguin
in antarctica
my list of places in the world
i've been lucky enough to go all over
the world but my list of places i love i
love norway norway is my is the most
beautiful place i've ever been i
actually genuinely think god was doing
belgium
and france it was a bit flat and boring
in holland a bit flat and bored and then
he got he got up to like nowhere he went
ah screw it and just went crazy and just
like he was just so
bored um
isn't it like a chapter at a
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
maybe that's where i got it from um but
it's just the most
yeah oh yeah exactly
yeah um but it's just the most beautiful
place on the planet it's absolutely
beautiful but actually literally the
places i love
are all cold places and the places i
hate are like saudi arabia
um
malaysia and i'd love to go in there but
actually being there it's so hot and so
sticky and the humidity in malaysia and
place like that and oh that's part of
the world's just killed me
but i was working at the time as well
probably i forget to go on holiday to
thailand now i'd probably love it but
the time i was working so it's a bit
like i hate being here i just swept for
three weeks i hate it
um
but um but but yeah
me i love the cold
i'm not a big fan of the heat
well
mcmurdo station antarctica would
probably be on your uh go-to list but
it's not as pretty and it's just you
know
probably i don't know you don't actually
have to go there on holiday there will
you
oh yeah you can take tours yeah
yeah
there's uh
i forget the name of the tours but it's
um
it's a through national geographic you
can take a recruit now it's a research
ship but you can take a cruise to
antarctica
no way okay you might
cost out the ass which is why i haven't
done it yet but yeah
what's the chances of dying
of like hitting something you shouldn't
or something you're not during tourist
season there's not much a chance to die
unless you do something stupid like i
don't know
and then they all get riled up all forty
thousand of them in the colony
because they're revenge penguins
the penguins are only a little at the
falklands you could take them out that
would be more like kick a penguin or
you're not going to stoop down to punch
your penguin there you'd have to kick it
like
like when you kick a baby
by the way i have been drinking a little
bit
that's not cold
which is why we're never going to make
it to our second anniversary
you know alcoholism rude behavior
yeah uh this child is only 100 only
minutes away from getting banned at any
one point
wait keep still having me on i don't
understand
hey
you're not the biggest problem you are a
problem sometimes only when you get
riled up
my sense of humor is the risk well if we
get banned it'll be because i say
something that i think is very funny
everyone else
goes be in trouble did he say this time
right
i will just say before we get into what
we want to talk about today because we
do we aren't going to just stand here on
top of things we will actually i'd love
to store [ __ ] frack your brains from it
think about all the live videos we don't
have last year are there any bits that
you've sort of remembered that you think
that was bloody funny i ever enjoyed
that see if there's anything that jumps
to my well i i think you have a clip
i do have a clip the most [ __ ] uppedness
that we have ever done in the last i
mean it was oh my god couldn't believe
it happened
i looked over
no we'll throw it in let's do the thing
because awesome
beautiful bean footage here we go
and welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv
a movie channel that's my little intro i
liked it wait
okay
star trek stargate star wars
this is my first ever video to get the
predators robocop
every other sci-fi or fantasy movie ever
made well this is the tv and movie
channel just for you
this is sidetrek so basically how do we
know that the federation wasn't being
run by down the throat getting to the
comments which started am i talking
about
i mean you see picard's face when he is
blasting these things with the phaser
it's not very federationy it's not very
sort of oh listen
oh let's respect all life it is a oh
gross kill
what episode
my
third ever
video
i made
[Music]
tv a movie channel that's my little
intro i liked it
and today i am i was always on a sunday
because it's super sci-fi sunday um
joined by the resident american himself
how are you stormy well i'm not drunk
it's fourth of july weekend it's a
miracle
i am here at the moment to do a very
important horrible last minute live
video because
i made a mistake
and i need to apologize to you i think i
actually need to apologize to brad
wright which
is really embarrassing
basically i wanted to like dress up a
little bit um
i'm wearing my star wars t-shirt um but
i wanted to represent the trek side so i
thought i'd do some some trill markings
on myself
um and what i didn't realize
is i'd accidentally use the permanent
marker
um so i now have
some very nice trail mark even
with my resident american i'm pointing
the wrong way
i'm here
hi guys and welcome to sci trek on
citrix sunday very warm a little bit
sweaty sunday here in the uk but um i'm
talking
to my normal american friends over here
not one but two americans do your god
save me now
did we lose spins
yeah basically i mean
good afternoon and welcome to sidetrack
your sci-fi tv movie channel and we are
i'm not
oh
guys
your sci-fi tv new channel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank god
today is not my birthday
[Laughter]
i threw that last little bit in there
because one i love animal animal was
always my favorite my picture
and
was always my i would love that as well
so that's my favorite but that was a
little gift for our shelley i don't
think he's on just yet but i might
i will send to the video just for her
later
but um
my favorite part was when spence you
know there was the episode where he
marked his face up to look like a trail
with a permanent marker and he kept
drinking and drinking and drinking until
he passed clean [ __ ] out on live
stream just gone he's just
it's like he was right next to my panel
right
and we just stared at it was like
i think spence is asleep
he didn't woke up with yes
it's so funny i remember a bit later i
didn't put it in but a bit later me and
you were talking and we sort of realized
that he'd sort of his head was over here
sort of thing you're like
did he fall out of the chair
he fell over
he was sit down and he fell over we love
spence more than anything mensah was
supposed to be with us today but family
commitments he's not been able to join
sadly um but the thing we're saying was
what what are you going to do next
spence um because of work commitments
he's not been on as much as we'd like
but we were joking that we should like
super glue two plates to his head so he
likes a ferengi
but um try to get the tympanic
tickle and it went really wrong
yeah i was just absolutely mad he was
very very funny but he was drinking the
whole thing but he never said to us he
was drinking red wine but he was
drinking it from a cup of that size
and just boom bitty bum bunny bun and i
was just like i'm getting more and more
drunk because if they went on
for me the thing i've enjoyed
and it's a little morbid really i
suppose i've enjoyed it so much some of
that
and stuff some of our debates on work of
being so interesting um
and particularly in the comments that
it's like generated afterwards um
because there's still people that do
shout vocal art that have actually
really thought about it and they're
talking those people is so fascinating
and then talk people that shout woke a
lot and i haven't thought about it and
talking to those people is just funny
um so it's uh i've really enjoyed some
of this i think we've had like proper
conversations over the you know
yeah they're youtube long and prosper
yes without a really good debate to not
shied away from too many things
shelley did you see the video
i don't know i don't think he did but
i'm just wondering if i can just play
the last little bit just for surely
wait a second i can't i can't i can't
wait a sec here you go silly little
present here
[Music]
today is not my birthday
[Laughter]
so i just made me laugh there was the um
the pink panther
and he goes up to a hotel bar and
there's a dog there he goes
does your dog bite and he's and then was
no my thug does not bite so he leans
down and goes to like stroke him and the
dog
i thought you said you dirt does not
bite is it bad yeah not my dog
i don't know why that just reminds me of
that
what is your gift shirley who does our
facebook page and got our facebook page
from like about 200 people joined like
1300 now so thank you so much shelly for
all your hard work on that she was at
the dentist hopefully that's sort of oh
i hope that went well ooh
where is uncle matt george flaxman says
well we do have a birthday message from
matt as well while we're doing little
videos we'll just throw that one on now
and then we can actually talk about
something that we want to talk about but
here we go
uncle matt
has been playing with his um
editing software and he learned how to
do something that i have now seen about
nine videos with him doing it in
um
you'll see what i mean
he does it a lot now
sorry about that
one yeah that's how long this channel
has been going is the first birthday of
the channel happy birthday to star trek
sorry i can't be here to celebrate with
you i am currently on holiday but happy
birthday
all the best
i want his t-shirt
see he's just rubbing it in the only
reason he did that is just to rub it in
the heat on vacation and we or
not today
he's got a nice week for it it's been
lovely
here in the uk how hot is it there in
california
just out of interest okay so
it's not as hot as usual
in my hobby it was uh rain like [ __ ] uh
but right now it's not today it's like
uh it
i'm trying to convert to uh celsius in
my head and i'm failing it will high
today will be 98 fahrenheit
that's like a million degrees centigrade
we've been like 22 23 degrees centigrade
i don't know what that doesn't found out
either sorry i'll have a look
uh
my phone
sided that sent there that fahrenheit is
for foreigners
and it won't tell me
so um
um but yeah um but it's gonna get hot
next week 31 32.
next week let's see what kind of uh
actually it's it's uh i think
you know where it's at least in southern
california when it's
we've had above
40 degrees centigrade i think we're out
of that phase now because we're
looking at 35 centigrade for the next
week
still it's miserable but it's better
than 40 plus
yeah we we did we did 40 for one day and
we all nearly died all of us
collectively was melted in a puddle
yeah
i don't want to know i mean my electric
bill is going to be like 500 bucks i
think it's just
my electric bill didn't change because
we haven't got any air con
kill me now
anyway
so
as we always do and thank you everybody
that's joining the the video stream i'm
gonna do a little bit of a rundown of
the thank you to people in at the end of
the video probably because there's lots
of people thank after one year harris
our other american might join us in a
little while so let's see if he he
attends so
on our first birthday
what have you been watching this week
stormy bear
this week has been busy
i uh caught up with uh orville
oh
last episode we should discuss the last
episode
two and discuss last episode wait let's
with a spoiler warning
spoiler warning if you haven't seen it
yeah i really don't have to go into too
much spoilers
some people
uh the old yorkshire geek who's on with
us
a couple of weeks ago we did stargate
video yeah yeah
hated it he didn't like it he said
complete snooze fest didn't like it and
now this is all opinion it's not doesn't
think any other thing didn't like it
what did you think is generally like
without spoilers just
generally i thought his standard fare
for the season
i haven't been
really jazzed about i mean it's been
okay i mean you know i it's uh the
orville has been something i i want to
watch every week but it hasn't really
i
it
used to be kind of really comedic
you know
uh and it really hasn't been i mean i
think this i mean when it went to hulu
it started addressing a lot of serious
issues
you know and um
but i it was okay it was okay it just it
wasn't
above the it didn't go beyond the
standard fare for this season
i said i i actually really enjoyed it
you did i didn't think i was gonna when
the video episode started again for slow
coop i will say no spoilers we won't we
won't spoil it
yeah
this is i'm with you on the season that
this there hasn't been as much comedy
it was almost like a parody
in the first two seasons i thought
actually
about i i think into the second season
the comedy dialed way back
yeah to be fair um but there's been very
little in this season this last episode
did have me i was laughing out loud in
in several places but it wasn't
silly fart joke humor that we've had
from that we used to from seth mcfarlane
it was just it was almost like
situation comedy humor almost like like
some of the jokes with
i can't say it without there being a
spoiler
are you saying like friends in space
almost
but but better
i watch a lot of friends still and it's
still funny but i um i'm not so not so
keen on it as i was 10 years ago but um
there is there is this there is a thing
with isaac that um he's talking to
thingie prime and he is inviting them to
oh sorry spoiler there's a wedding and
he's inviting them to the wedding and um
and the kaelyn prime's sort of like oh
would you like to come to the wedding
yes i would like to come to the wedding
oh i know first was like well why would
i want to come to that wedding what is
it
and then say something
all units come he goes yes that would be
lovely and then so okay we will leave a
defense detention fine and we will all
come and then isaac doesn't tell anybody
and four thousand warships turn up
and i just that that was that generally
made me laugh out loud i was generally
thought that was very funny
um but i thought there was a few bits in
this this last episode that were very
funny
but the season from our finale for me
was episode nine episode nine
was bloody good
i mean properly good
um that is some of the that's that's
really good sci-fi such a nice
circle to the story arc of the uh
lieutenant commander i've done it i've
forgotten her name
i know the other day
and the lady that lost her love of life
from the start and hated isaac holapse
the whole series anyway actually oh yes
yeah
so i i already thought that was great
but i what do you think do you think
that was the last episode of the order
okay so first of all
for uh slower cuber
my little spoiler is over so we're
talking about other [ __ ] now
maybe i don't know i mean
i don't think it did it did it get
enough uh did it get enough money for uh
hugh hulu i guess that's the
uh the common denominator that we're
looking at how many people watched it
yeah yeah
i don't know
i don't think we'll know that straight
away um
i watched it
you watched it that's true
yeah um so i mean it has a fan base
that's a start it definitely has fan
base i love that they actually spent
enough money on it this season that it
actually looked like they were in space
yes i remember the one episode remember
they want to say they're in a
two-dimensional space
that was one of the worst it was an
interesting episode it's quite funny but
it was one of the worst looking episodes
the special effects was so bad
um but this this this season actually
had some good effects some really good
battle sequences
i hated that little fighter thing but
you know it was good in the end i'll
take it with a little fighter thing i'll
take one
i'll fly i'll take one but don't get me
wrong give me a give me a go would be
great
um
but but yeah i don't um i didn't didn't
particularly like i well you know things
that kept annoying me it was everything
was telling me show the shuttle bay
shuttles used to have coming in to
basically fly over it was like trying to
miss it and it's like why don't you park
it somewhere better but anyway um
i i do think this last episode did have
a bit of fun it did feel like
it felt like the final episode to me it
didn't i think seth macfarlane
definitely had one eye on we might not
have a fourth season so let's
end it in a nice way and see how we get
on and then if we got a fourth season
it's fine because like there's nothing
like final no one's left or anything
um
but you know
they did kind of finalize saying the
only thing and i may admit it may have
been a bathroom break but the the
the only thing i recall that really
wasn't
wrapped up was
his daughter
no the daughter thing isn't wrapped up
at all um and there is now the build up
for the conflict between
um bortis's people
who i forgot the name of
and the cli
uh and then obviously now the human and
their relationship with me
yeah for the um k line without sir
megalon
uh yes yes that's right yeah i always
think that sounds like coffee
i was thinking you need to go and order
a coffee can i have a nothing
whipped cream please and some nutmeg
um there will be one probably
um but but yeah there's so there's
there's interesting there's that
interesting thing there the the
relationship between
the union and the kale on i think i
think that would be interesting to
explore if they get another series
because that's a difficult relationship
but um i just loved i love bortis i can
i just thought he's great
so
great it is a great he is a great
character because his elvis impression
oh no
he always remind me like you know if um
i'm sorry there's a grandchild screaming
i hope you can't hear it you know it was
like
it it was just all it was just a really
it was played really sincerely to the
heart and the character had heart
especially all the conflict with the uh
child between him and his husband
i thought that was it was just a really
good character and well acted i thought
actually that storyline was the most
interesting to me than all the other
conflicts
the whole bit at the first of this
episode didn't make me cringe a little
bit
okay we won't spoil it for you
but it doesn't really
um but i like i just love it when he's
just like when he's singing and stuff
and then he just stops and you may go
now
i know people like that um
well i i really really enjoyed that i
thought it was great um
i've rewatched
um episode
nine of strange new worlds
um because after the passing of michelle
nichols
um i thought the strange new world's
episode i think it's nine
um it's the penultimate episode isn't it
with the um i think what you described
it perfectly it was like aliens meets
um
yes
someone else meets someone else is it
but yeah um but those little egg things
and that's really a good uh episode i
thought so i thought i'd watch that
again
i put a michelle nichols video on and i
said the only uhura and most people went
there r.i.p or horror and michelle
nichols what a legend you know um
stood up against racial hatred back in
the day you know martin luther king jr
had to actually talk her into staying on
the show and that's the comment one guy
went
um
isn't that a bit insulting and i went to
who go to the other actresses to zoe
senagan and the lady that is in stranger
worlds
yeah
i really don't think they're going to be
bothered about me saying that the
original is
is the only you know
they always praised her
you know and uh
celebrated her and her achievement
because you know they've clearly said at
least uh saldana said well for what for
her there'd be a lot less black people
in leading roles in film today
and um great singer
yeah
andrew you've missed everything andrew
you've missed everything
yeah come on um a storm you did a strip
i didn't sure it was a match i'm not
wearing pants
it's 90 something degrees over there if
you are implantably really i'm amazed
that you're wearing a roll neck jumper
how are you alive in that t-shirt
i was in my pants at one point when you
got up to 40 degrees
uh so something other things i watched
was uh the last episode in the latest
episode i should say uh for all mankind
uh this is on uh apple plus really
excellent show if you guys haven't seen
it it's um it's what it's kind of like
the last the life of nasa if the soviets
were the first to the moon
and it's a really
really great drama uh it's uh produced
by the same guy that was a show runner
for deep space nine and battlestar
galactica remake a lot of more
yeah
it's just i it's just an incredible show
um
i'm still looking at keeping up with the
like an episode a week of resident evil
uh you know
jay hates it he just
i think he's getting ready to vomit
right now but i kind of like it it's
okay i don't like it enough to vomit on
it
that's reserved for very other slimming
small projects
i don't want to hurt myself i just don't
i don't like zombie stuff
i never have to i never liked walking
dead
you didn't you see i'm getting ready to
dive back in
i lost track of walking dead when i
moved from oregon to california
i just i think i suppose that the zombie
apocalypse would be the easiest
apocalypse to sort
give me a rifle and enough ammunition i
just i could slaughter thousands every
day you just wipe them out really
quickly absolutely it's not a terrifying
it doesn't scare me i suppose
um you'd lose you know maybe like 25
percent of the population while
everyone's sort of like ah what's going
on and then you would just slaughter
them
but maybe that's me being a bit harsh
i'm
still going through my uh re-watch of uh
deep space nine i'm about five episodes
away of the final one uh they're getting
ready to go to the fire caves
and kywin has yet to figure out that the
guy she's [ __ ] is gold the cot oh my
god woman
the space
i swear to god space karen cannot get
her [ __ ] sorted to save her life
also um umbrella academy still with that
i mean
it's mental and i don't want you drunk
oh don't want to drunk
yeah um something i saw this week is
really not sci-fi but excellent and it's
called agora it's an older film
it's about um
the uh the philosopher hypatia
and how she was
huh
i have i thought that rings the bell i
think i might have seen that
rachel wise was it was in it rachel
agora excellent movie did shitty at the
box office but excellent movie
the
thing i really want to talk about and of
course no spoilers
the the latest thing from netflix is
sandman
yeah
if you want to talk about that i'll sit
my fingers because i'm watching it
tonight
holy i mean
we now know what happened to all of
netflix's money we also know what
they're broke as [ __ ] the production
value is amazing the wait for the last
day i bend it to come out
it's amazing
writing is and i've just seen the first
episode and
it was really good
it's it's based on a graphic novel
wasn't it
yes yes yes but i i looked into it
because i didn't realize that
constantine and stuff was in it so it
was a dark horse
dark horse right
[Music]
but i didn't realize that it was like
constantine and stuff i know i know it's
now like jennifer constantine or
something right
i mean it's you know it's probably neil
gaiman's probably his best at least from
my perspective his best work it's just
i remember reading it uh when it first
came out as a graphic novel and i was
just blown away i mean it was
let's go comics
yeah yeah yeah vertigo yeah yeah and
sandman is just
god of mine do i have copies here i have
the entire series someplace bound
but
it is excellent and and and um
those people that were poo pooing on it
like oh it's going it's not gonna be as
good as the comics this is one of those
rare instances
where the story is actually really comes
to life in the uh
in in
in the stream i mean it is
i think streaming services i've just
i've just recorded a video that i'm
going to put up thursday about films or
projects that mistook in like
development hell that would be much much
better if they don't do a film and they
do a streaming service um
theories instead because they want to do
like a night rider movie and i'm like no
no no no no forget it it'll be rubbish
do a series 8a team and all these other
projects but um but the dark tower is
one
and they did a movie it wasn't very good
and because they tried to cram too much
in
streaming
yeah double budget
two or three series and i was and i
think the sandman from what i've learned
about i didn't i've never heard of it
when you said months ago really what
they're developing this is amazing it's
one of those graphic novels that never
really got big over here so i never
read it when i was a kid
um i'd never i'd never heard of um
constantine until kenner reeves movie
came out
um
but um but that's why i was quite
surprised really because i was like i
read a bunch about a constantine stuff
when the film came back i loved it so
much i wanted to you know you know
invest and i never heard of sandman
somewhere
um
but um
it's one of those things that are
reading about it and and and capturing
right
it's oh man
it could never have worked in a movie or
even a serious movie could never work
there's too much going on
um
and even if they strip out and strip
down its bare bones a little bit with
something they've got to do in these
things there's so much detail in a lot
of the graphic novels you can't just put
in it makes no sense but
um yeah i'm quite excited to watch it
i'm just hoping i can get the wife to
watch it and so that um
[Music]
the overall is more track than star trek
um except for strength
um that that yeah i hope my wife will
watch it so then i'll be able to watch
it in the evening and i won't have to
like hide away and watch it we should be
good
it i think
it appeals to a broader audience and
maybe star trek maybe
you know it is more
it's more
sorcery than science i i guess i mean
you know the main character the fur and
if you've this is really not a spoiler
uh the the main character is is a
magician is a sorcerer
uh a character in the first episode and
it is
i mean it's just it's just fabulous
not science but it and it's really not
fantastic
fantasies
well it's dark fantasy i guess it's not
like music
yeah it's not a documentary so we're all
good i think i'm talking about not
sci-fi i finally finished watching um
dexter um first blood or new blood
oh really i haven't even
ended brilliantly if you like this
original series of dexter
which i did i thought it was great
um
yeah i was disappointed that night sky's
been
excuse me
i've been cancelled as well
um
yeah uh residents oh come here you
resident alien is i didn't enjoy the
second seriously but i enjoyed the first
series did you have you watched them
stormy
which which one resident alien with anna
alan tudic
no i have not seen that
watch the first series and see if you
fall in love with it because
particularly if you like alan tudyk from
um
uh the firefly and another thing he's
just he's just a great start but the
second series it got a bit dark
there was the first series was a bit he
did murder a few people but a bit more
reverse comedy got a bit dark and second
series but i just love it i love him as
an actor he's just fantastic but give it
a go um i don't know what it's on in
america it was on um i think it might be
on hbo over there probably
not sky over here sky atlantic if
anything's on sky atlantic in the uk
it's normally hbo because i think
they've got a deal because we haven't
got hp max over here so everything goes
on sky instead
but um
i'll tell you what paramount plus is um
viewing figures have come out
and it's only been going a few months
i've already got 450 million subscribers
which is about 30 over what they were um
hoping
and they do say that the bulk of that is
down to star trek um really well there's
going to be more track then i mean
because
it went when uh
oh god what did they call it it was a
cbs all access i think it was a couple
years ago i mean it was you know it grew
fast but not fast enough according to
their budget you know then it became
paramount plus and they got other
other storylines other dramas you know
and plus all everything else that was in
the cbs and the paramount catalog it
seemed like they threw up there they
seemed like they finally got traction
but you know it's
they've gone into new markets for
paramount plus because obviously we've
got a plus here for a few months so that
will have pushed their growth figures as
well but they're just reading a story
today about how they've considered
steady growth where we're stalling
netflix has actually shrunk amazon's has
plateaued
um hbo max's has apparently plateaued
even though they've been trying to catch
and disney's slowing still growing but
slowing about paramount plus has been
and i'm like other than star trek on a
couple of movies there's not a lot on it
here in the uk
i like it because it's got prodigy and
all these things that i've that i
haven't got to see up till now even
though it wasn't nickelodeon i never
thought to look
i don't know if i've got any clothing
actually
um but
for me like the one reason i like
pyramid plus other than star trek is got
my local news on it which uh
i don't i don't you know have cable i
only do streaming and so you know the
local bakersfield news channel is on
there live
yeah it's a little cuba's got a question
for us
and we've got a good reason to watch the
second season of space force my wife and
i got several episodes in so far it was
insufferable
loved most the first season
yeah
i thought the second scheme wasn't much
the same of the first
it's um
i don't know it seemed like a little bit
slower paced it got a little bit more
serious and then they canceled it so
um if you go watch uh the remaining
episodes at your leisure
there was nothing
there were some good gags some good
story lines but it was just
i invest your time in sandman it just
wasn't just you're right it just wasn't
as funny was it they they did make it
more serious
without a point to it though and i don't
know if they made me could try to make a
party political broadcast maybe more
than a show i really think the reason it
suffered was because they tried to
produce it during the high heights of
covet and it was just
missing some pressure that's pressure
maybe but yeah now the second season
it's it doesn't go anywhere
really to be honest
um i do not i have not seen evil
i've seen it advertised but i haven't
watched it yet i have not seen it in i'm
going to see sandman today the most on
aliens and space
um he's the chap that he joined us on
the live stream alien space uh he was
the chat with all the toys he's got a
wall just full of toys it was amazing
welcome god i wish my wife would let me
know
um i'm going to get him on on a live
stream at some point and he's going to
he's got his own youtube channel to do
some interesting videos
um but yeah i watched this week my main
thing is that i've watched and i've done
two videos on it because i woke up early
yesterday morning to watch pray
the predator
and it wasn't on it said it's out on the
fifth so i woke up early on the fifth
i was going to watch it before i went to
work because ah brains
stupid disney stupid mickey mouse don't
punch me with the face and stupid face
um so i was quite tired yesterday so
what i did instead was i went to work
really early and i knew that's an excuse
to leave early so i couldn't go watch
pray
and i ended up watching it three times
um
i know you haven't watched it yet stormy
but
it's brilliant
to be honest
um
it's again we want to have spoilers
because you haven't seen it but um
it's it's it's just it fits the the
point
of that you know that it's in the
setting the comanche nation it's not
going to be like this big action movie
and there's low technology
but it's actually
thoughtful about the comanche nation and
how obviously the history there and
things so it's got that tone so it's a
little it's a little slow in places but
it's slow on purpose and to a point
but somebody said to me um oh seven
minutes of action at the end
and a 90 pound girl beats up the
predator and i'm like that's not
the film you didn't watch it i was
genuinely like
oh my god this predator's going to kill
it oh and it's like i was genuinely like
on the edge of my seat at times in this
movie it really builds the tension
really well
can i just say that
joan of arc
was not a big person
joan of arc was a slight woman as she
was described and kicked a lot of ass
i'm just saying i just want to throw
that historical anecdote out
a 90 pound woman if she has driven
especially by god can click kick the
[ __ ] out of you
i just want to say uh who was it bob
you know talking about the arrival for
1996 saw the arrival i thought is
excellent
um [ __ ] man on site on cyworks i shot a
lot of video at the radio telescope that
uh charlie sheen's character worked at
it's in uh
actually it's right up the road from a
house in mojave and it's called the
owens valley radio observatory
i did some ufo videos there some carl
sagan stuff and it's just
it's an excellent location if i'm
talking about space [ __ ] excellent
location drop out in the desert and
set a telescope in the background yeah
look at the arrival i thought that was
good the look in the in the the moon the
second arrival uh but the first one with
charlie sheen it was really really good
um
some guy replied to me on youtube
yesterday's
um
i like douche um
yeah i had a few that all the comments
people about slagging it off were saying
that not your pound girl night pound
girl night pound girl
and i just i just can't get my edge
around it because the whole point
that arnie was a massive
muscle-bound thing and his muscles and
his soldiering skills didn't matter
they they were completely irrelevant and
he was very lucky to have survived as
long as he did
and the other muscle group bound
warriors
that were with him
died
yeah
exactly um
and the thing was it's like
yeah i'm just thinking about seeing the
prime examples but yeah funny people
claim this working for getting filmed
but
in this movie again without spoiled no
spoilers because that would be boring
and stupid and but
they've done this film very cleverly in
that she's not a threat
and they they make the point very
clearly that she's not a threat so in
the original
duke is um lucky to survive till the end
he could have been killed he could have
been the first one they killed because
the predator wasn't he didn't save eye
till the end because he was the leader
he wouldn't have known he's just lucky
really so he survived long enough to
learn how to fight him and then he was
lucky to get covered in mud and survive
yeah in this one you know there's it's
it's that the predator doesn't consider
her to be a threat that's the point
that's how and she's watching and she's
learning
how to defeat him and then in the end
she kicks his ass
and then other people are going on about
how weird the predator looks because the
whole point is it's supposed to look
like i mean for one read the read the
the law read the books read the comics
with all the you know the material the
whole point is that the predator is
supposed to be evolving
and he's like genetically modifying
himself and stuff but also actually the
the the the
the design is actually based on some of
the artwork that was done by the
original
um creator the the first person to
actually model the predator and it was
one of the designs he did is
as different predators look so it was
actually based in canon anyway and the
feral predator whatever but it's
supposed to be like
a predator 300 years ago that's the
point
was
i got a question concerning the uh the
canon
in the film aliens versus predator alien
versus predator
wasn't there
maybe as lance hendrickson has said this
line or something about um
the the origins of predator on earth
started with
them battling alien they had this whole
thing where they go to earth to battle
the alien the fsavp yeah with the
pyramids and everything right right and
so then the predator
race discover well you know
these little humans they're good prey
too
and isn't that how they picked up on
earth it was just a random planet that
they could battle somebody else on and
they said well you know the inhabitants
here
they'll be good enough you know
yeah
what was that i mean i may have that
wrong i'm just was that part of the
canon
we well it is canon unfortunately but i
mean it is
forgotten about a little bit in this
movie because the technical that's
supposed to be set hundreds of years
even before
uh prey and obviously ray has been very
careful to try to create a predator that
looks like it's two or three hundred
years before
the arnie predator whereas
i didn't bother um but but i think the
whole thing about the predator evolving
really came through in uh predators and
then the predator is when that that
whole idea that the predators slowly
every time it
fights a new prey it learns and adapts
and gets bigger or gets stronger or
changes
things and everything but um for very
heroic ask
well for me predators um predators is
the second best of all the prejudice
movies
before prey came out pray for me is just
it's it's it's a worthy
film it's the one form that hasn't got
predator in its title but it's the one
that actually deserves to and i was just
i did a video yesterday to talk about
how annoyed i am that he didn't get to
the cinema that way this has gone
straight to streaming and i'm just like
i would have loved to have seen this
film at the cinema it's um
it's a real shame
soldier was really good it was
uh
i think uh
it was uh one of the
one of the films that holds the record
for the least dialogue yeah
yeah i mean he got like you know his
contract you know if you break it down
for a number of words he said like 90
dollars per word
or some crazy thing like that yeah
i love that as well the guy that was um
the guy that loses his eyes then he's
only allowed to think and they said oh
well he's got no depth perception and
i'm like close one eye you don't lose
all of your depth perception i suppose
you do lose some depth but distance but
i was thinking
um
thank you andrew um but yeah i loved i
loved um
so it's a great story with explosions
[Laughter]
isn't that the mark of a great movie it
is a great love story with explosions i
base all of my great my my gloves on um
my wife will go i just want to watch
this film
how many people blow up
and she's just like nobody it's a thing
is you granting it no
[Music]
i don't really want
want to watch it i i think that's a good
point aliens in space is made is prey is
unpredictable the whole time you go
he's dead and then he doesn't oh well
he's definitely dead and then they don't
and then they'll be okay and then they
all die will you make up your mind it's
brilliantly directed really really
really well done and
i have a little bit of news on prey i'm
just wondering if i should tell you or
sure hold it now i'm going to hold it
i'm going to do a video um i do know a
little bit of fun information that
somebody's told me um
that's not shocking really to be fair
but i'll save it for a
video it's our first birthday we need to
focus on that today i'm gone
um
pray was
excellent whatever
this week i don't think i've watched
anything else this week
i finished my old job and i start a new
job on monday so finally good good
um
and it's um so i've been sort of focused
on that i've been wrapping all
all that up
so even though you can tell i've done
quite a lot of videos this week because
um i don't think i've done a full day
i keep going like two o'clock i'm like
i don't know nobody cares what i'm doing
nobody even knows i'm here i'll just go
nobody cares
um my manager was like uh what people
today and i got that thing done for you
oh thanks what else did you do oh well
i'm after that [ __ ]
for that
what are you going to do you're going to
tell me off i'd go on friday
um so yeah that was good but um no it's
interesting
i just wonder where you feel though
about
people that are angry about films like
um
prey
and then lord of the rings
um project and all these things of this
if they go into this
i could tell by a lot of the comments
that i had that they'd go into it
deciding this is stupid 90 pound girl
cannot
um defeat this i'm i'm not going to like
it
um and i think that the whole new
thing is with with lord of the rings is
people going to like that because do you
think
do you think that actually affects
everybody goes into with preconceptions
don't they with a new project yeah
with anything and you'll go into a film
you look at the end of it you go i said
just don't fancy it
you know i i don't think there's
anything better than a film that you're
expecting to be rubbish and then
absolutely love i think i just think
that's great that was my experience with
matrix i saw the commercial said oh god
this is some sort of crappy hacker i
just
you know cuz
what was the
johnny johnny mnemonic
was what i thought it was going to be
if anybody remembers keanu reeves and
johnny mnemonic
yeah yeah
i thought that's what it was going to be
and it was like let's hack the dolphin
brain
and he was like oh god i don't want to
see more hacking of dolphin brains i i
just wasn't then someone said no man
you've gotta go do you understand me
you've gotta go save that matrix and you
gotta do it okay fine i will punch you
don't question
and so i went to go see it and i said
well jesus if they just made the trailer
you know tell something i would have not
been such a schmutz about it and i loved
it
it wasn't what i thought it was which is
what it was advertised to be
oh yeah i just
remember to when that was worth dolphins
in secrecy remind me about that i know
right
you know there's a big thing about them
remake in movies
again what slower needs to well with the
worst dolphin since sequest dsv
yeah
yeah that's better
they're going to remake sequest it's
coming back
they're going to reboot it
apparently it's in early very early
development this this might be a little
bit of um a exclusive another damn i
should get it
um
uh disney have got hold of of the rights
and they are potentially
um wanting to develop a sequest dsv
uh thing i think the rights were held by
um
was it universal
it was universal and the spielberg uh
yeah yes but spielberg owned it
basically and created it uh so it might
have been amblin that owned it but
disney have
oh they don't they haven't bought the
rights but they've bought rights to
produce so but it looks like we're gonna
get secret dsp and if we get the first
series of secrets dsv i would be very
happy
um if we get the everything else of dsv
then uh
i'm not so happy
and i don't want to watch it apparently
it's on peacock at the moment i forget
who owns peacock
it's not here and it's not in in the uk
um
will new seacrest have an animation over
the end credits yes why not um c lab
2021 that was brilliant i love that um
but but yeah that's one of the things i
i would like i i will be very happy if
uh if seaquest dsv if that gets off the
ground it's one of those things it's
they pick up these things a lot don't
they and then probably about one in
three actions gets made yeah
um but yeah if they if it gets off i'd
be happy with that i just love this i
love how like they had the the the hall
was grown and it got it got sick that
was a proper star trek episode and then
they all actually started to deteriorate
but the first series was great with them
roy schneidering
um
and i loved i loved it was i took my
snide a couple days ago jaws and
everything
twenty two naws 2010 uh well what was
the one with the crazy helicopter blue
i was talking about blue thunder with
somebody
and uh my father-in-law hates blue
thunder because he was a helicopter
pilot and apparently he'll go he refused
to let anybody watch it was saying
it can't do that it can't do a
loop-de-loop damn it
um and he gets very angry about it and
i'm like it's an experimental helicopter
and some helicopters can do loops loop
so come back yeah and you know the red
bull the red bull helicopter team used
to go to air shows and do uh
rolls
exactly the links can do
there's only a handful of helicopters
again the apache can
um you need a varying pitch um blade
configuration apparently not all
helicopters have it but um
but yeah i i i'd be happy with that blue
thunder is a is a film they should
remake i'd watch that i like that an
experimental police helicopter and then
do a bit of politically intriguing type
thing and that would be
so we could talk about it
can we make it woke
can it be a warp helicopter can we call
it
i'll tell you one project that i've got
that it's got woke written all over it
uh let's have a quick look let me think
er did what was it
oh alien nation
so
they've been trying to remake alienation
it was woke enough the first time around
yeah i know but i just know that when
that gets green lit and gets finally
announced which apparently it's pretty
close to getting greenlit
um initially at the moment they're
looking at a movie but there's rumors
that it's they're going to switch it to
a streaming extra series
um
but it when that people are going to
moan about that because that has got
woke all over that is going to be about
it's i have undertones of race and
everything else
running all the way through it so people
will get i think
fallen skies bob yes i remember before
this guy was a fantastic tv series that
was spielberg as well wasn't it um
this spielberg
yeah i think yeah i think it one was uh
connected to it um noah wiley
yeah you've got the link
paris
so so here going back to alienation so
are they going to do the james khan
version of alienation are they really
going to do the gary graham and eric
pearpoint version i think it's going to
be hey did you google that
well i knew eric pierpoint was in it
because i saw something he was also in
this last week oh my god
paris honestly's with us but his webcam
isn't working but
yeah we can't see him it's a w oh hold
up but the the the the two themes of the
uh the movie versus the series the
themes were a little bit different it
was i really do think that the uh
[Music]
the tv show was more woke
then hello harris how are you
oh my god he finally made it i don't
know a little late but uh i had to come
support
happy birthday
thank you
sir
are you wearing one of my t-shirts i
sure am
good mom look at you you gotta gotta
support where we can you know
i'm not even wearing that t-shirt that
looks good in the white i'm happy with
that yeah
you can get that on desktrack.com
the long t-shirt one
well done
right
yeah [ __ ] yeah that is the team to go
for i have i've sold more of the sgu
i don't know what's wrong with you
people
anyway sorry story we're talking about
alienation um it'll be a hard reboot to
be honest so it'll be oh so
harris do you remember watching
alienation back in the day there was a
movie james khan
um there was a tv series that lasted one
season and then there's a bunch of tv
movies but we're talking about like a
late 80s early 90s
yes mid 80s go back and watch the movie
um the film district nine was basically
a direct
virtually direct remake yeah
very
smooth
same story basically but an alien ship
full of slave aliens
lands on the earth or breaks down in los
angeles
the newest immigrants to its shore
yeah um and then the whole movie is
about the first alien
um to become a police officer they'll
become a detective isn't he and it's
he's partnered with
and it's a bit of a
buddy movie
um i can't remember the nickname for the
aliens somebody in the comments will
tell us but um flags was it
i think what's that no i think that was
um
uh space boom
san francisco yeah that was his name
um
i thought they just misspelled san
francisco
yeah
that's why they all had names like that
um
but but yeah um
oh there is supposed to be a sequel for
district nine coming
um but
getting covered sort of put it back and
but as far as i know it's still on the
go
i can look and i aim to be pro for that
yeah george is his nickname yep slags
okay it was slags but um that means
something very different here in the uk
a slag isn't it it's a fun girl
you'd want to meet your mother we'll put
it that way
um
but yeah that's um it's a
just a brilliant
i'd love it but it has got woke written
all over it for me if somebody comes in
and makes that with an agenda which
sometimes happens
it it could be awful um but if they make
it
like a proper sci-fi series oh it could
be great it was one of my favorites by
the game and i love the series um who
who was the guy from the tv show
was eric point there at pinpoint yeah i
loved him and he did he's one of those
actors that appeared in so many series
over the years and he was brilliant
enough
so fingers crossed that happens that
would be great
and gary you know uh eric pairpoint and
gary graham both were in
uh star trek enterprise
everybody was in star trek enterprise of
course he was a vulcan yeah he was an
ambassador
yeah of course he wants in eric
pearpoint he was hunting some sort of
fairy thing on a dark rogue planet
as you do
yeah i mean that's nice like every other
sunday for me
and before we go live
um
i have been waiting for you harris yeah
i'm waiting for you ah um because i i
don't have enough bandanas in my life
and then gotta get here under control
somehow we were talking about the a team
earlier and that's what that was but
anyway
yeah well if i if i dressed uh if i put
a bandana on immediately my wife would
just immediately come in and rip off my
head and say stop it
but
the we did have a bit of star wars
news this week
and
isn't this your competitor man oh yeah
it's just the only hat i had on the desk
because
yeah i wore this to a spacex interview
and
ah that didn't go anywhere
they probably thought you were maybe
taking a pic well you should have worn
that to your other interview and maybe
i don't know my other interview result
was like by text and a phone call it was
just bizarre they read my linkedin and
it was like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we
need him
it was the craziest [ __ ] ever
that's some 2022 stuff right there yeah
it's
it's yeah zoom call real quick
please come work for us
please please give me the job
and uh my brother's an engineer and
there's there aren't enough engineers in
the uk it's a massive shortage so he
goes
and goes so why should i work for you
and that's how he has how he gets goes
on interviews now and they just beg him
please please come work for us i mean
why should i where's your cafeteria
what's it like
are there taco tuesdays
it's getting thursdays this is important
what
do we have fish and chips on a friday
dress down fridays this sort of thing
yeah
but he works in nuclear power plants so
he does all right he glows orange but he
you know
um
yes we had some star wars yeah little
drop so the trailer for andor
dropped oh yeah that was this week did
you like that trailer yes i wondered
what you both thought
i liked it a lot uh i was
the only hesitancy i had with andor i
think it's going to be great uh is just
the lack of aliens
i feel like we're in star wars and it's
just people again
and that
i feel like if this is the beginning of
the rebel alliance we should feel as
many aliens as possible see as many
aliens as possible because that's where
the rebels really were because the the
humans were the empire and they were
kind of nationalistic in that kind of uh
sense where there was human pride and
human storm troopers yadda yadda
we need just a few more aliens but it
looks fantastic everything else the the
only other thing is it looks like
they're holding ak-47s are are those
glasses yeah i just that was kind of
unsettling but you know i was like okay
you look great and i love uh both the
gilroy's and the entire cast so i
i've got a got high hopes for it uh i
was looking at the ships like crazy
it's um that was what i was looking at
in the background all the different
ships and i was i was very impressed
because oh that so fits
between the two you know and
i imagine that scene where we see a um
star destroyer come over the first time
and everyone's sort of like oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be a bad day here in andor
yeah but i imagine it's supposed to be
the first time anyone has seen one and
that's why everyone's sort of like oh
crap
probably one of those flashbacks because
it looked like there was a flashback of
clone troopers as well walking into a
town
which is uh
hopefully they bring him back a little
bit
well that's where it's going to sit
isn't it it's like it's it sits where
in a in a period where we're going to
see a bit of both aren't we from from
the first three and then and the clone
wars
going through to new hope and it's it's
five years before new hope i believe
um
somewhere i'm not real sure i think we
might get some flashbacks uh
further in the past as well i'm not
positive by any means but uh have you
all watched bad batch the other animated
series yeah yes so
it seems like they're gonna be clone
rebellions at some point like clone not
clone rebellions but i guess little
clone civil war within the empire
maybe we get to see a little live action
parts of that uh with andor
i don't know
i'm hoping that might just be kind of
tossing a
a line out there but i hope it uh hooks
let's be honest like that that the
hardcore fans would go crazy if they if
they blended between the animated
universe because
when they when they started doing these
animated things bad batch and then uh
i'm sorry in the clone wars first of all
i think they they did it as a
kid's cartoon really but then they
suddenly realized that everyone's
watching this and bad batch was not a
kid's cartoon
that was just like
we mean this this is serious
it's it's so i mean in the first season
of clone wars is is the most childlike
but there's still decapitations every
episode people losing arms and just like
yeah
star wars happens in this world it's
great it's not it i feel like a lot of
that translated uh from dave filoni you
all know dave filoni
he's kind of like uh george's protege i
guess uh but he he almost directed not
the whole first season but a good chunk
of the first season of avatar the last
airbender which is also a
fantastic kids show but not that much of
a kids show at the same time
uh
fantastic world building and i don't
know that's not what i mean
i'm looking forward to the live action
um
netflix have spent 15 million dollars an
episode on it so it's it should be good
they also kicked out the creators of the
show though
the original so it could
i hope it doesn't shine alone they were
trying to force it to go
a different direction and then they and
netflix get fallen out of them
apparently so they got they got moved on
quite early on in production but um but
but that's star wars so yeah yeah i love
the animator i think they took a a
decision very early on with the animated
series to say
this has to be canon
so you know because a lot of the time
you see the animated series like the the
ewoks cartoon this one it's not really
canon it was supposed to be a size thing
four kids and it was just a bit fun but
i think with those with bad bats
whatever they said no this has to be
canon so what have what happens you can
draw it but it happened then
oh yeah we can sort of go across all the
genres and if and so yeah i'd love to
see that i think that would be amazing
if they sort of reference bits of that
i wish they did didn't they because um
you know we saw was it who's the dude
with the forearms i want to say goku but
that's not right is it
uh
at the very end of the trailer that one
little uh alien shot we did get
um
no no no i mean sorry from um clone wars
and he was in the cartoon and he was now
he was a general oh general
grievous
and then we actually saw him in
he he actually went between the cartoons
and we saw him in everything didn't we
or am i making that up we saw him in the
movies and we still have animated didn't
we
yeah
um and obviously you got that chick with
the um
i don't know star wars as well as you
guys do i'm sorry
but she's like all the names she was a
padawan wasn't she in
wars yeah and then we see her in later
didn't we see us we saw her in mandela
um yeah yeah she is cool in that and the
actress they got plainer is stunning
but um i'm quite excited about that i
think it's an interesting apparently
series one is going to cover a year
um in the run-up to
this is all running up to it'll blend
into the start of rogue squadron so that
for you and then series two will cover
the next four years running up to
rogue squadrons and obviously then go
straight into new hope i think that's
brilliant we're going to see the
rebellion
we get to see not just like a pocket of
it we get to see the actual rebellion
grow from inside the senate well i'm
interested with the senate this this is
probably going to be a very political
series but i think that's going to help
it just flesh out star wars which is
what the series are for but
uh to actually see what was like
happening i guess in the mindsets of all
these people that you're getting
glimpses of
uh
it just expands the world in a great way
because all those worlds are still under
under a separate type of struggle
you know against the emperor you know
how that led up to how they were
compromised and there's a thousand
stories there
really and and they got the money to do
them too
but i think they are going to do them
because disney will bleed
every last drop out of star wars this
squeeze
but there are thousands of worlds to
stop pigging going back to
really ted more tatooine really yeah
let's just have another serious based on
tatooine please because that's what we
need
um
i don't know we don't
california desert
yeah that's that's this seems to be what
it is because they've they've bought
some land and we're like we're gonna
film all of the star wars films here and
it's just like now let's go somewhere
else um
they could do so much yeah you know in
in
and star wars does the very same thing
there's this place uh in here in
southern california called the alabama
hills
you know i was watching deep deep space
nine you know and then uh cisco goes
after the orb of uh the uh emissary and
it's like dude
you can see the owen salt flat right
behind there i've hiked through there
yeah that's the trail to it's like oh my
god you know and there's like joshua
trees from here to yonder and
everybody all of hollywood seems to come
out to alabama hills if they want some
sort of desert scene
and it's like everybody's seeing those
rocks i mean even you know uh
marvel does it
yeah
yeah hey stargate my favorite show on
the planet it all looks like british
columbia
yes
um amazing
yep
um but now i'm looking for that because
i actually think this might be the first
star wars story for a little while i'm
actually like excited about like i can't
wait for mandalorian to return because
i've fallen in love with that character
um i need to start making notes about
where all these different bloody series
of time
so where's this set up right okay i'm
going to do myself a graph and figure
out how we can set your chalkboard
yeah exactly and like to start drawing
them in uh spider diagram sort of thing
no you know some of those murder
mysteries all the photos and they put
string between them look at themselves a
big murder board with a right where does
this episode fit um
but but yeah this is the first one i'm
thinking i'm watching thinking like yeah
this is a story i'm excited about and
rogue one was just i just adored that
movie i thought
there are some days that might be my
favorite star wars movie not every day
most of the time it's empire strikes
back but usually if i'm watching rogue
one like the week after i watch it i'm
like yeah that's my favorite star wars
movie it's great
yeah exactly yeah i think it might be
it's definitely my favorite out of the
[Music]
other star wars movies if you know what
i mean
um
i think this might be my favorite other
than the like a new hope and
and empire strikes back and you know the
original three other than that i think
it might be my favorite it's pretty it
was such a clever film i was just sort
of like of course you would make that
um the best bit was the end though
oh
darth sid
shit's getting worse
i was thinking about this the other day
and as as a proper star wars fan harris
what would you think about
i i was wondering whether they should
now the the special effects have got so
amazing they can sort of like do this um
you know they can make luke skywalker
look younger have you ever seen that um
youtube video they did when they did the
battle the fight between obi-wan and
darth vader from the original and he
says right if it was done now and then
it's a proper like they're [ __ ]
and they're properly going at it rather
than the old man fighting they do in the
in the film
whether they really in in a new hope
yeah
yeah so
you know obviously you've got them sort
of fighting but obviously don't i mean
like um obi-wan kenobi nothing was a
very old man
um then somebody's actually done like a
version this is what it should have been
and then this is just epic battle
between them huge you find out on
youtube it's amazing
i was just thinking that
i know they did the
remastered version a few years ago
before the new films came out and they
added more spaceships to the battle
how would you feel if george lucas
tomorrow went or disney tomorrow went
right we're going to do a new version of
new hope and we're going to add loads
more cgi and we're going to replace some
of these scenes that are a bit awkward
and we're going to replace the battle
between darth vader and obi-wan and make
it [ __ ] epic
how would you feel about that or would
that be like no no the original is the
original leave it below
i'm kind of like the original needs to
be the original but at the same time i
i i don't i don't love like the the
whole george going back back in there
and putting jabba cgi later and things
like that but uh
forgot about that
i mean they've already done that a
little bit and it didn't pan out all
that great which is kind of what would
make me hesitant i guess
not that disney would have a higher
standard than george or anything like
that but i feel like disney would
try to make it look
good so there might be some kind of
leeway i could give it there but uh
i don't know i i i have seen a couple
youtube videos of that fight extended
and i like them but part of it is which
which
obi-wan i guess at the very end the
series did a good job of portraying like
yeah obi-wan can still fight if
necessary he just has to get a good
mental
standpoint whatever it may be
uh i think that fight's a lot more
purposeful with it being so short
and that's what i like about it so i
don't know if i'd like it extended all
that much have you all seen in the
animated series rebels
yep yes that might be my favorite star
wars content the last two seasons
uh
but when when obi-wan and maul
in rebels that's
beautiful because it's it's
so simple and so short and it's each
little uh
cut has gravitas behind it you know it
you can almost see the story
going across the the slash
i think that's kind of similar with that
uh
maybe it wasn't meant to be that and it
was meant to be just kind of a simple
little battle because that's all they
could afford at that time uh and that's
all they could really do because they
had alec guinness trying to swordfight
real quick a little old to do that back
in the day uh
but i don't know i don't know if i'd
actually like that to
be extended or not expanded
all right
it was
i really would love to see that kind of
thing you know now i think that would be
that'd be awesome anytime you get in a
really good
you know uh
sword fight on star wars it's just it's
awesome
but
i don't know i sword fight you idiot
yeah yeah
so i
sadly i've got to wish you guys a
good day i've got to go run and do work
[ __ ] so i apologize
but happy birthday
happy birthday to sidetrack
well i think i think we're gonna say
it's been an hour and twenty years but
stormy thank you so much again very very
good
you never let us down and um
you know as american inherit
sandman
yeah i haven't started watching i need
to watch prey and sandman today and
tomorrow
yeah yeah all right guys you take care
thanks for having me on
your team stole me back bye
oh i've got to cut my fully separated
properly
um but yeah i mean
we'll talk for five minutes and then i'm
gonna have to go because i can hear my
wife go in you [ __ ] said an hour you
[ __ ] said an hour i can hear her in
my thing but uh yeah i i really want to
know what you thought about it because
what did you think about the
so
the storyline that the time bit where
they're going with andor um i said
the growth of the rebellion stuff i just
think there's so many story lines there
that i'm actually like genuinely excited
about
um
i don't think i've been excited about
any
star wars you think other than maybe
when the last three started
well
i think one of the things that makes
this so exciting is that we know they
have an end goal we know that they have
the complete story thought out uh
to a degree at least maybe they are
they're still figuring out stuff for
season two but they said you're starting
to film that in november so probably not
figuring it out all too much
uh
that's i mean that's that's what we kind
of were hoping for when disney got on
board and we were like all right if
you're gonna do some sequels plan those
things out
george gave you the scripts
do it and then
they switch it up a little bit and that
we can get into that a whole different
day
but at least plan something out and i
think this is the first thing they i
adore the mandalorian uh john favreau
was one of my favorite directors and
just he smashed out of the podcast
and uh dave filoni and him together is
just magic oh it's great
uh but i don't even know if they have
everything fully planned out i think it
would do them good talking about all the
warner brothers and kevin feige and all
these different things going on
take a week take two weeks take a month
and then figure out the next 10 years
five years yeah yeah
um i thought here's a good point
actually because it is nice to know that
they've got a final thing i i wish
they'd stop jumping through time
constantly
it's it is it like i i do like star wars
but i was always a trekkie
but i like star wars
um i'm not obsessive i say we jokes that
um except it's not joke we're going to
do it we'll have a video where we talk
about the politics of star wars and i'm
going to sit there and you can go nuts
and i will sit there and say
now
no mate you're reading between the lines
and i'm just like because i know you
guys have really thought about this [ __ ]
that'll be a long stream well let we'll
do it um yeah
but um somebody's talking about remaking
indiana jones and they're making indiana
jones
i haven't been reading the um the
decides i'm sorry i missed a bit there
guys
but um
yeah update the special effects like the
original star trek episodes yeah why not
um well that'd be how that came from
they might remake casablanca raiders the
lost ark um a new digital version of
those sorts of films
i i'd almost
we'll go back to let me let me remember
about that and we'll come back to in a
second
i wish they'd stop jumping
around in time i hope they'd stick to a
pattern because then it's it'll be a
little less confusing for me because
every so often mandalorian i didn't
realize it wasn't set after the last
three movies i just thought it was after
the last three movies
and then i realized i'm wrong
after the first just after the first uh
isn't it
uh yeah number three um
are the empire strikes back isn't it
yeah just after that and i was just like
uh
richard in the jedi show yes you're
right i think my bad um so um so i i'd
watched the first series before we last
was like oh
luke's here
yeah then it's hard to gauge exactly
where that takes place is it five years
after that three years after that is it
happening like we don't know right after
well because a book above
book above effect is what like locks it
in isn't it because he can't have been
in the belly of that thing for years can
he no he was in there for
weeks days months whatever it may be it
means that whole to two seasons of
mandalorian is set really close
but with boba fett they
push it into
forward into the future with uh i think
the flashbacks are kind of closer to
return of the jedi where
flash forwards are closer to
uh mandalorian and then probably where
rebels ends and things like
that go back to i said my idea my silly
idea about remaking these classroom
movies are more digital and
because the technology is so good now
you can make actors look like they did
30 years ago
yeah real quick though on on the time
thing
yeah i think you're going to be very
happy because they're about to go all
over the place the acolytes said 400
years before they're also doing tales of
the jedi which is essentially what i'm
hoping it's like is the clone wars
between the phantom menace and attack of
the clones because there's a decade of
stuff that happened there
but also
tossing us all the way back there
tossing us behind the original trilogies
bad batch is still going on so we're
tossing things maybe obi-wan season two
as well so that's still in the middle of
that
uh it's like every 20 years we're
getting a little segment of things
acolytes can be set 400 years in the
past
um if they do any of these series like
lando series or anything like that it's
gonna be another 20 years in the future
i'm hoping they sort of cut those out
because i mean after the the the
[ __ ] that was solo
i'm hoping they don't do that but i will
see
with technology now we could remake or
instead of remaking a film like indiana
jones and
the raiders the lost ark
you could
go back with special effects now
and just like upgrade them
and then re-release it like re-release
it like a new like a new movie but you
could upgrade
so because of limited special effects
back in the day you could fix all the
crappy special effects you could add to
it you could you know and do all these
things you know you could
you could you could dial them up to 12
but you'd still have the original core
would you want to see that or is the
slightly shitty special effects from
films like
raids the lost ark or even indian
johnson last crusade when he he drinks
the wrong he chose poorly and he just
melts
um because it was a physical effect
rather than a cgi effect or is that part
of the charm
i think it's part of the charm but
if if they're adding things i'm going to
have to lean into no but if they're just
well george well no george was adding
things and digitally retouching if
they're just digitally retouching with
the technology we have now
i'm iffy but i'm
sure you know because we if we're still
able to get the original version and
they don't just toss that on disney plus
or something like that afterwards and
take that version off then i think that
would uh help me change my tune i also
love to see
the original version put on disney plus
at any point
yeah exactly they should bring it but
yeah they should because it's just the
the modified vision i i i have a
slightly different look in it because i
love it when like a director's cut comes
out
you know
20 minutes extra footage and you know
like and even though sometimes sometimes
it adds to the movie sometimes it
doesn't and sometimes you just get oh
this you know you enjoy the movie you
think that's a really weird scene that
you've forgotten about and it's like
because oh yeah x is the director's cut
and
but other times you're like why didn't
the directors cook why wasn't that the
cinematic release this makes so much
more sense now what was the editor
thinking you know sometimes it can go a
bit miss i would consider that like a
director's cut you know if they still
created the lost ark and they said right
what we're going to do we're going to
fix all the special effects we're going
to create this and we're going to do
something else with it and
and we're going to release a 2022
version i would like i don't think it
would take anything away from the
original but but like you said i don't
want it to replace the original i want
it to be
i don't want a choice of which one i
want to watch maybe
but then then you get into the question
of
you
would you rather have steven spielberg
come back and do that or would you
rather like a studio like lucasfilm
thankfully and lucas is alive to do the
other other things
that's a problem because if you get
somebody just completely different they
could bastardize it and they could
become just a mess they could have they
could go with the right intentions and
the tone just not fit too yeah it's like
zack snyder cut of the um you know the
the league
um
you get the original filmmaker to go
this is what i wanted to do but i'd love
to think about that that would be okay
so if steven spielberg tomorrow came out
and went right i am going to spend the
next six months and i'm going to with
special effects people and we are going
to fix
the um raiders the lost ark
would that then be okay is that
something to be excited about
yes anytime spielberg says anything i
i'm pretty excited i wasn't excited for
west side story honestly i still need to
watch it but that's just because it's
another reboot in the midst of a bunch
of reboots i'm sure it was good but
that's if spielberg is saying something
original and he's gonna come back and do
something original please please
cool
this is like if james cameron said you
know what i've got these brilliant ideas
for aliens
and but we couldn't do it at the time
but now i'm gonna do it and we're going
to make this film freaking epic
and you know it wasn't epic enough as it
was but i mean that would be something
i'd be like yeah baby and special
effects
i would rather see that than a reboot or
a remake
100
uh because then it might bring somebody
back in that wants to make an original
story off of that then you can get an
actual
continuation that we might
want and not just kind of scattered i
don't even know what's going on with
alien and predator are they in the same
universe technically still
well
it depends on whether you choose just to
ignore avp requiem altogether
yeah
personally i i just deleted it from my
brain
so
it's a nice nice ability avp music
some fun
it had some fun bits in it i did like it
when they had fun
but no it was not a good film
um
you know what annoys me about that
because you were talking about prey
earlier um if you're going to watch it
later on it's no spoilers again if
anybody's in but it's it's it's
brilliant it's really really really good
um
so um
it's a different tone to the movies but
it should be and you can definitely tell
the directors 10 cloverfield the lame
director it has vibes of that but it's
also respectful too
to the time it's set you know
yeah oh my god it's really really good
um it fits more with predator
um one two and predators than it does
the other films but we should delete
those other films from our memories
because they were awful
um good predator in particular it's just
like
i went in there with so much hope
it's quite good in places
yeah predator
and people
who all who all act well in it it's just
it's just
that the end was the worst bit though
the end was like oh look we've got
predator armor yay
what are you going to do with that
swearing
um it was just awful
um but uh
i just i've just wasted two hours of my
life on that [ __ ] and through my remote
control of the tv
but um
yeah it was right but pray is fantastic
that's all i've been hearing about it
and i'm
so excited it's got literal like
comanche parks right
yeah well you can um yeah yeah they're
all crunchy it actually was filmed in
english and comanche
which i love um and the director um dan
trachenberg clattenback
um he's basically that's one of the
things he loved about being able to do
it on the stream and service that they
gave him the option to do that and there
was less pressure so they were able to
do that um
i wish we'd had a cinematic release i
really do i think it deserves a
cinematic release i thought it's
fantastic
yeah but look at the special effects and
look at like how they develop that look
if you think about from a technology
point of view in the predator i just
love how they did it they they really
there's loads of detail in there that
are just loved but i watch it three
times yesterday
good i mean that's great character
development but it's it's legitimate
world building as well which is what i
like
when i get good world building in
something that's what makes me really
happy and
predator lost that
the predator and a lot of other things
lost that just by
not necessarily diving into concepts but
yeah but for me predator one points to
the predators and their prey they're the
films the rest of them
we can just delete
where would you put prey in your top
predator i guess
it's not rashmore
predators
predators and prey are pretty close for
me
okay um i think prey just edges it
because it's it's got a little bit more
um
gravitas to it it's got a little bit
more um weight to it
um but
predators for me is the film avp should
have been had nvp was always supposed to
be that that it was a and then
right yeah nato reserve humans drop in
there's aliens the predator is all set
it all up and that is that was the way
avp was supposed to be um
and i just think it would be an epic
throw aliens into that it would pull the
dogs out of predators and throw aliens
in instead that film is epic that would
have been insane
um
oh they lost opportunity they missed
opportunity
um
this new twitter store we want cinematic
releases
i tell you what honestly if we don't
have cinematic if we don't actually
start getting annoyed about this soon
we're going to lose cinemas and that's
what scares me because i love the cinema
and i think it takes away
from a movie when it doesn't have a
cinematic release it
i've forgotten about too quick i think
the whole last two years especially if
you remember uh when like black widow
was coming out tenet was coming out all
these films were just
just being released in theaters for the
first time after what we hadn't had
theaters for a year a year and a half
people were there were a lot of people
online that were saying ah i'm not gonna
go to the theater again just
put it on streaming i'd rather watch it
in the comfort of my own home anyway and
just
i i can't get behind that
it takes away from it and i don't like
my tv is quite big and i've got a nice
sound system it's not the cinema
no i like that i can pause and go for a
piss but
but you lose the experience yeah yeah
exactly and i mean it's um
going to the cinema is expensive enough
if people stop going they'll put the
prices a bit more and we can't do that
but um
no i i think we're gonna have to start
getting angry about this so we're gonna
start losing them and our kids will go
remember that time that you went to the
cinema and you know it'll be something
like nostalgic for them and i'm like
yeah it is a problem and people are
inherently lazy if they get a chance to
watch something on the tv at home they
just will they won't go
i i try to go as often as i can just i
mean i i'm lucky that i live in la in
that matter that i can just kind of hop
in there uh
i wouldn't sell bodies bodies bodies
yesterday which is coming out this is
like a sort of it's advertised as a
slasher film that's coming out next week
[Music]
you just need to go sit in a movie
theater every now and then that silver
screen is magic
the reason we're talking about the
things we're talking about right now i
mean
sitting sitting at home would not have
brought that same uh experience and it
wouldn't have been as long-lasting
i feel like a lot of that with is just
kind of
we're in that especially americans over
here just toss some content in front of
our face and then toss some more once
you're done toss some more right after
that here's tick tock too and i mean
everything down they're doing it
everything becomes just the same if you
do that too much
a good example of this why we've got to
protect our cinemas
um
during the covid pandemic obviously new
films stopped going out but my cinema
was still open for a bit and they just
made it like two seats apart sort of
thing intune bits you know then it
closed together to open again but but
what they did was they they showed a
bunch of old classics and we went to go
watch harry potter and that was nice to
watch the cinema again but the thing
that really sort of like well this this
this is amazing this is why cinema is so
amazing was we saw the original uh
jurassic park
at the cinema and we were like
the special effects still stood up and
it's just oh yeah but i'm just like i've
seen this film probably like 15 10 15
times now but this is like watching it
again for the first time
and then
it's so different
yeah it's just it's just so much more
impressive i was grabbing on to the
manager on the way to go get die hard
get die hard
get predator get the president yeah
bring his predator back oh my god man
but they did they showed predator i
couldn't go
but that's what cinema should be doing
as well they should have a nostalgia
night an acid in the present but they
should do they should have like every
week like a tuesday night something
they'll go right we're just playing an
old classic die hard lethal weapon
predator predator you know all these
films that they haven't shown for 40.
they showed the first top gun and we
were straight there before maverick came
out and it was a full cinema it was a
full screening of top gun
that's so uh well i
don't mean to don't mean to brag again
but los angeles isn't perfect for
it's not perfect by any means
but we get to see a lot of movies all
the time and tarantino's movie theater
the new beverly
oh maybe it's on sunset or santa monica
uh just west hollywood and uh
he always has classics going he he picks
a couple new things every now and then
and he'll put some new things he likes
out but he always has classics going a
lot of them are if it's his movie he
always can toss that up or it's a movie
he produced but he has
i think butch cassidy and the sundance
kid always playing
there there's a couple ones that he
brings back like super frequently it's
just it's amazing
uh there's a couple
rooftop cinemas that do that kind of
stuff out here and it's nice
um
i believe there's a lake cinema
showing uh
uh oh my god what is it i think the sand
lot is this weekend but next weekend
it's not jurassic park but they're doing
something along those lines and i'm
heavily debating going excuse me it's
better to go see it on a large screen
with good sound
it's just like you said it's a
completely different atmosphere isn't it
and now it might be my local cinema
they've got much better seats that
recline
and you don't have to be close to people
it's great
so because as an englishman again if i
can touch you you're too damn close i'm
like oh so so i like the name
even though i do can occasionally watch
kids hit the film you know films that
the kids want to see you know i was it
don't have to go and watch
i was snoring very heavily little guy
cover what it was superb
the kids wanted to watch it and i'm like
okay whatever
layback's like sprawled out brilliant
best snack
yeah it's dark and who cares if it's
loud and it has flashy things it's
if you fall asleep it's great slip
through
it's
that's the only problem i fell asleep in
vengeance the other day it was just too
late i decided to go to the movie after
the bar bad idea
right okay we are going to call it an
evening sir all right well for morning
for you but thank you so much for
talking on harris it's really really
appreciated um and for for purchasing a
marvelous t-shirt from
scitrek.com um which everybody else
everybody please do the same i need the
money um
uh again it all helps me to convince the
wife that this isn't a waste of my time
so
um
and again just just thank you everybody
that's helped us in the last uh 12
months uh shelley matthews jumped on the
channel harrison you give us our time
stormy gives us his time every single
week
um people that have joined the channel
like um oh god andrew and people like
this that they just give me a little bit
of money every single one so you can
join the channel hit the join button as
well
um i start a new job on monday i wish i
wasn't i wish i was doing this every day
but you know what you're gonna do
and not that you'd want to see this
every single day
um
but but you know you could
don't um hit the join button hit that
join button
my eyes are in harris mccubed but yes
please go and join harris on his channel
he does some great videos i don't
approve of you swearing this much so sir
uh hello [ __ ] no i don't like it
i get it uh edit it out for that first
minute can't demonetize myself that fast
you know
yeah there you go why not oh no you
substitute it out and it's your
personality and you should always put
your personality through thing um i i'm
lucky that i've got kids so i don't
swear as much if i did this channel
about 10 years ago every other word
would be f
yeah why we saw that [ __ ]
but now i've got kids i try to
try a little bit
shelley's actually on the facebook
channel she's got a picture of the mug
and i'm really jealous it's really
really nice i wish i could buy
everything it was on the products but i
haven't but it's got like the black mug
with the sidetrack logo it looks wicked
you can give yourself
80 discount or something right
there's no discounts on there but what i
did was instead as i just put the prices
as absolutely rock bottom as possible so
i don't make much money on any of them
really
um i've been a bit of an idiot really
to discount yourself on there so you can
get a little bit everything oh i can get
it full cost i can get it for cost but
it's it's still quite expensive
it's it's expensive enough that if i
bought everything on there i wouldn't
make any money at all which is um not
actually i'd been quite a massive thing
but but there's also about
there's about 50 or 60 different
products
there were a bunch yeah you got a lot of
good things on there
yeah well it's a nice way you do it
because you put to do the design and
then just put the design on lots of
different so it's really easy to set up
on lots of different sorts of products
um
and but then i have to go through and
check that it's all come out alright and
takes ages but what i've done is that
yeah i don't have a discount code
but instead
i've just put it absolute
bare minimum prices i make two or three
pound every item that sold i don't make
much
so please and know that you are helping
the channel but also i'm not fleecing
you so
because like the jump is like 450 quid
i'm like i'm not charging somebody 50
quid that's just stupid yes
so yeah no
baby clothes yet i love that do you want
sidetrack baby clothes do you want to do
to that do you give that to your baby
seriously write the baby up real quick
y'all are gonna be great for halloween
yeah i can do sidetrack baby clothes i
didn't think anybody would want it
so i didn't
i could get wrong
there's like
phones and all sorts you can do but uh
um but anyway
i'm losing my voice i'm getting a sore
throat um yeah shelly comes from another
channel but so she's getting some
can't show my favorites okay
um
she's got another channel that she
supports i stole her from to do can you
come do my facebook group and she's like
yes please they're just like thank you
my group's my channel's there so right
anyway
harris thank you so so much mate we'll
see you next week if you're available um
and we will do a star wars video very
shortly because you can explain to me
why i should like star wars more than i
do
shortly and not so short of a video
well that's if you want to go into the
politics of course
we'll make sure we've got several hours
available okay okay
and so see you soon
thank you so much and i will see you
very very soon and everybody
here's to several more years
maybe yeah
a decade two decades
i believe
i'm so tired
doing this and a full-time job
i'm so tired you don't want to stare at
screens all day
that sounds like a great job for two
decades if enough of you join so that i
don't have to have two jobs then i'll do
it for the next 10 20 years okay deal
there we go 500k subs down there that's
next subscribe to the channel and join
the channel and then i will keep doing
it there we go
that's a promise
see you guys see you next week on sunday
back as normal
see you ciao bella
[Music]